- Une opération qui demande
beaucoup d'effort
et d'attention.
Ce chêne de 7 tonnes
doit d'abord être soulevé
avant d'être scié.
La poutre doit être réalisée
à la perfection étant donné
sa destie chantier
de Notre-Dame de Paris.
PHILIPPE SEYNAVE, propriétaire,
Wood sur mesure
- La pression, elle se fait
vraiment forte. C'est qu'on n'a
pas le doit à l'erreur, c'est-à-
dire que, bon, ça peut arriver à
tout le monde de rater un bois,
mais làmais làmais làmais là, o.
Là, c'est une pièce, un bois,
donc il faut toujours être
derrière la lame, toujours
regarder, vraiment, être...au p.
- Spécialisée dans le traitement
de grands arbres, l'entreprise
Wood sur mesure, dans le nord
de la France, a été sélectionnée
pour un contrat inusité :
fournir des dizaines de poutres
qui serviront à reconstruire
la flèche. Cette pièce majeure,
ajoutée à la cathédrale au
19e siècle, a été emportée par
les flam trois ans.
- J'ai déjà fainc là,
on en a encore une trentaine
à faire jusqu'à la fin du bois.
- Le chêne traité aujourd'hui
a une significatio
particulière. L'arbre,
qui a environ 180 ans,
a été coupé dans la forêt
d'une ville voisine.
À l'instar d'autres communautés
rs le pays,
la municipalité a décidé
d'en faire don à Notre-Dame
de Paris.
JEAN-JACQUES THOMAS,maire de Hin
- Il y a un formidable mouvement
de fierté, et c'est l'occasion
de leur dire : voyez comme
notre forêt est belle, voyez
comme ce chêne, son grain est
beau et il est sélectionné,
et c'est un peu une partie
d'eux-mêmes qui va
se retrouver à la capitale.
- Pour Philippe Seynave,
menuisier et ébéniste
rès de 3rès de 3rès de 3rès de t
est particulièrement important.
Quand vient le temps d'aborder
l'héritage que laissera le
travail réalisé dans sa scieriee
dans la conversation.
- On est quand même partis
au moins pour 200-300 ans,on va.
Après, j'espère plus, quoi.
Donc, on a notre nom là-bas.
Donc, nos petits-enfants
penseront à nous, quoi.
- Il faudra pas moins
de 1000 chênes coupés dans
tes régions de France
pour reconstruire la charpente
et la célèbre flèche
de Notre-Dame de Paris.
Cette partie des travaux doitdé,
avant la réouverture de la
cathédrale, qui est toujours
prévue pour 2024.
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,